una cinta sobre el nueva york de los
años 80 y una fantasía animal fueron las
propuestas que examinó el jurado en
cannes
el estadounidense james gray vino a
cannes con armageddon time una cinta con
mucho de autobiografía que cuenta la
relación de un niño con su abuelo y un
amigo afrodescendiente en una sociedad
donde reinaba la lucha de clases james
gray inscribe la historia de esta
familia que sufrió la persecución nazi
dentro de la gran historia de eeuu en
momentos en los que el país daba un giro
a la derecha con la elección de ronald
reagan y el auge de la familia trump en
los círculos de poder
[Música]
por su parte el polaco jerzy skolimovski
trajo a cannes una fábula poética
protagonizada por un burro de ojos
tiernos eso es el nombre de este burrito
ex filtrado de un circo privado que va
de aventura en aventura una cinta
experimental con pocos diálogos y mucha
belleza visual
el carismático actor omar si se dejó ver
por la alfombra de cannes en el estreno
de tierra ya una impresionante cinta
sobre los soldados senegaleses que
'francia enroló a la fuerza durante la
primera guerra mundial
de área
a primera hora del año omar si firma
aquí una interpretación de antología en
los zapatos de un padre de la etnia
fulani que parte con su hijo a una
guerra que los africanos no entendían